Warning, this episode may contain
content that is not suitable for
children. Viewer discretion is advised.
Welcome everyone to LED Live. Today
we're going to answer the question, what
does the TV show Lucifer teach us about
God?
Find out on this episode of LED Live.
[Music]
light exposing darkness.
Okay everybody, cats out of the bag. We
are talking about the TV show Lucifer
today and the Christian Post did an
article a few years ago about the most
watched TV shows by religious families.
So I want to take a look at that list
and we'll we'll see where the uh show
that we're talking about falls today.
Okay,
that'll be interesting.
The first one was This Is Us. You heard
of this show?
Nope.
No. I bet you it's going to be this like
twisted show of like what the what the
modern family is going to be like.
Well, I don't know. We're not we're not
analyzing all these. We're just kind of
like going down the list. Okay. So, this
is us briefly. It's a series about the
lives of uh families of two parents and
their children in several different time
frames. So, that's kind of their angle.
They bounce back and forth in time.
Uh the next one was this on Fox is a
show called Star. You ever heard of
this?
Yes.
Yeah. Yeah.
What do you think it's about?
Destiny's Child.
You're pretty close, actually.
Is it really?
It revolves around talented young
singers who navigate the music business
on their road to success. So, very vague
title, but or vague description,
but yeah, that's what that's about.
How truthful it is.
I don't know, but it seems like it'd be
very appealing with all the talent shows
that are available nowadays that you can
watch.
So, the next one, How to Get Away with
Murder.
Now, that that's interesting. So wait,
these are shows that Christians are
watching.
Yes. Well, the way that they phrased it
was religious families. So I'm guessing
that they're lumping in probably in
America, majority of those are going to
be rel, you know, Christians, probably
not just,
you know, if you look at the
demographics and what people identify,
mostly Christian.
I remember seeing a news clip on this
and he was like, uh, what does he say?
He's like, murder, sex, and this, and
those are the tame episodes of how to
get away with murder. And I was like,
"Wow."
Yeah, for sure. I I actually I used to
watch that show.
You used to watch that? Okay. Oh, no.
So, why? Give us why.
Well, I like crime shows and like
documentary types.
Murder mystery.
Yeah. Especially like the psychological
ones. Um, so I was like, "Ooh,
let's check it out."
So, if you had to get away with it, you
want to know how.
So, what's the title mean?
Well, the title's pretty true to the
show
when it said Yeah, that's true. But I
thought it was going to be along the
lines of, you know, how people get away
with murder. Okay. And then like the
dynamics of the court versus the person
and maybe what strings they pull and all
that.
And you totally got sucked into
something else.
Yeah, for sure. How to get away with
murder. It's talking about So this
person, she's a professor at a law
school and or a university
and basically her and her students, five
in particular, get into some trouble and
they get away with murder.
Yeah.
So it's like law students beat like
trying to beat the system.
Beat the system. That's kind of what I
would have judging by the name. I
thought this chick is teaching you how
to get away with murder like Pretty
Little Liars or something.
Yeah. And in the midst of all that is
the sex and the drama and all
everything else that sells on TV.
All right. So, let's go to the next one.
Here we go. The show that we're talking
about today.
Lucifer.
I wonder what this show's about.
Who could it be? Who could it be? I just
can't imagine. Could it be
Satan?
So, you'll notice down there he's got a
little pentagram cuff link on his uh on
his suit. He's always dressed in a suit
in this show. Just kind of interesting.
You know, he's always dressed well.
Um
it's kind of like opposites for Angel of
Light, but then this is like dark and
red and
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's kind of
interesting that each one of the those
things that you've shown really have
like really kind of not wholesome
qualities and and I find that kind of
fascinating if this is what like
Christian families are drawn to,
you know.
Well, look at their options. I mean,
when I was growing up, I remember there
were shows like Little House on the
Prairie, Highway to Heaven.
Right. Right.
My mom used to watch Dr. Quinn, Medicine
Woman.
Yeah.
Those shows are still out there though
or shows like that.
They are. So, I don't know like what
what are people choosing to watch, I
guess, is the question. All right. So,
brief synopsis on this. I'm just going
to read it briefly. Okay. Bored and
unhappy as the Lord of hell, Lucifer
Morning Star abandoned his throne and
retired to Los Angeles, right? The city
of angels.
H where he teams up with the LAPD, in
particular, a detective named Khloe
Decker, uh, to take down criminals. And
as part of this, he he has a nightclub
that he owns. It's called Lux. It's kind
of like a high-end, you know, nightclub.
And uh, you know, so there's lots of the
things you just described. There's lots
of alcohol. There's lots of uh, you
know, lots of sex going on and and just
pretty much complete debauchery.
So, he's a good guy almost.
Yeah, we'll talk about that. You know,
how how the spin on this show like his
character Yeah. He's he is portrayed
very much as a a good guy. So you have a
lot of sympathy for the devil in this
show.
Well, that's why it's called Lucifer,
not
It is called Lucifer. Right.
Right. Right.
Right.
So, this was put on by Fox. They ran it
for three seasons. Okay. What do you
think happened after three seasons?
It got canned.
Why do you think it got canned?
Uh, I don't know. I remember hearing
about it getting canned and and actually
remember reading that there was a lot of
people that were upset at that which is
kind of like disturbing that our society
is is is seriously fascinated by you
know the arch enemy of God.
Yeah. So there was a watchdog group
called 1 Million Moms and they actually
did a petition to have the show removed
from network television you know citing
all the
things that were in it. But that's not
actually the reason that it got canned
ratings. Uh, well, you wouldn't think so
because of this next thing that I'm
going to show you. So, here's Tom Ellis.
The show goes for three seasons. After
three seasons, this starts trending on
Twitter. Number one, what does it say?
Save Lucifer. And how many does it have?
36.6,000
tweets.
Okay. So, this is after season 3. And
they say they say, "Hey, let's get this
thing to get another season." Right.
Okay. Does that mean it's the number one
worldwide
number one hashtag at that time?
Wow.
So by the next day, a million tweets
for Save Lucifer.
Wow.
You guys this thing,
you know, really shot up there and and
got a lot of people's attention. And so
what happened is it got picked up by
another network.
Netflix will play anything.
They will pretty much. So Netflix picks
it up and they do season 4 and then
right now they're in the middle of
producing season five when they started
airing it on their network. This is the
poster that they released. You
kidding me?
And if you zoom in there,
of course he which is literally so
blasphemous. But I remember actually
when these billboards were coming out
and and you would see them in like New
York or something and it would talk
about he has risen and and there was a
couple other hashtags. I don't remember
what or the little titles, but they were
messed up.
They're definitely not shy about the
Christianity or references in the show.
Yeah.
But Christianity isn't the only thing
that I think they're putting out there
in the show as we're going to see here
in just a minute.
So here's another poster. I thought this
one was also kind of interesting,
especially if you kind of zoom in down
here to the bottom.
See this over and over and over again in
Hollywood stuff, right? It's good to be
bad.
But of course, the Bible tells us
otherwise in Isaiah 5:20, it says, "Woe
to those who call evil good and good
evil." We are not supposed to be mixing
those terms or saying, "Yeah, everything
that's bad is good." That's not the the
picture the Bible paints. Just jumping
off of like what we've talked about with
the minions, cuz that was kind of the
Minions tagline. It's good to be bad,
right? That in fact, they even use that
exact same term.
To me, this is where little kids get
exposed to these innocent little tag
phrases and then this is like the adult
version of that. You know what I mean?
So, it's like they're priming you when
you're young, but then it's like they
feeding you this kind of content when
you get older.
Yeah. When you grow up, it's not so
unfamiliar. That's right. It's a
familiar message. Did you notice on the
on the poster he was just kind of
walking out of the gates of heaven? He
didn't get kicked out. He was just
Or is it the gates of hell?
Might be.
But I I just think it's interesting that
we're at a a state where people's
mindset is
we're saying save Lucifer.
Like that doesn't disturb you. He's the
cause of all this pain. And that's
Lucifer like #1 million. Like that's
it's not just the world. It's Christians
too. Wasn't that show on the list of top
five shows?
It was number four out of 20. But here's
the thing. Just like Thanos really being
a description of God, I mean, they've
been putting this idea out there
constantly that God is evil and the
devil is good. And this is obviously um,
you know, down the road. They're able to
give this to society and societyy's like
accepting of this mentality.
Yep. Okay. So, now I want to show you
guys a clip from the producers
and what they have to say about this
show.
So, because it is a show about the
devil, do you often refer to the Bible
to get kind of inspiration or ideas,
we often do to make it kind of a
foundation of of what a story might
spring from? So, we'll take a character
from the Bible or like we just took for
this season this flaming sword, which we
made kind of a hodgepodge of things from
the from the Bible, mainly this sword
that was supposed to guard the Garden of
Eden. Yeah, I'm gonna cut you off right
here because you're telling spoilers
from the upcoming episodes, but uh
am I?
Am I? No, we didn't talk about the
flaming sword.
Nope. So, uh that's episode 14. So, you
guys have a little preview of what's
Oops.
Uh
we got the scoop people.
Oh, no.
So, uh
it's okay. Um it's actually a good tease
of what you guys are about to see. And
that's the kind of things we're playing
with, which is things like the the
flaming sword, which you will learn
about meant to. That was totally
intentional. Um but uh but that's the
thing is we use it as the basis for so
much because that's I mean I'm a lapse
Catholic. I grew up with all of this
with w with with all of these stories
and and all of this mythology. And the
question is what are the parts that help
us tell story about Lucifer? What are
the parts that let us tell a redemption
story of a character? It's funny
because, you know, there's a lot of us
are religious or have grown up with
religion and and like Tom who plays
Lucifer, his his he comes from a family
of ministers, pastors and and you know,
a lot of people heard about the show
when before we had aired and said, you
know, what are you making the devil a
hero? Is that really something you
should be doing? And we're really not. I
mean, he is a hero, but what we've been
exploring from the beginning is is is
that there's there's dark and light in
everybody. And everybody can also be
redeemed. Everybody can be for forgiven.
And if you can forgive the worst person
in the world, then that's divine. Isn't
that what God and religion is about?
I actually think ironically, we are one
of the more Christian shows out there
because we're a story about redemption.
And that is what Christianity is
supposed to be about. At least in in my
experience of it. It's supposed to be
about, you know, doing good deeds, about
trying to be the best version of
yourself. And ironically, that's I think
one of the things that our show affirms
week after week. And it's one of the
things I like about it is a show about
the devil might say more about the
positives of Christianity and those
ideas than others.
Faith and faith.
I think that's the attraction of it. It
kind of questions everybody's belief in
whatever
by turning it upside down. You're still
looking at the same thing but hopefully
from a fresh perspective.
You got to be open-minded for sure.
There it is. Right.
Okay. So there's like wow.
We could spend an hour on what these
people just said right here.
Yeah.
I mean I don't even know where to begin
with that. That the the idea that these
these are the producers. So these are
the people that are literally driving
how this thing is playing out. I mean
they are the ones that are literally
making the executive decisions on
direction and all of this. And you know
they said it themselves they came from
Christian backgrounds. He's a lapsed you
know believer right and here it's like
well he's not the hero. Well actually he
is the hero and and you know what I
mean? It's like redemption like if God
doesn't redeem the devil God's going to
be evil.
Yeah. Yeah,
even in the movie Noah, we saw like the
fallen angels were redeemed and things
like that. We see that all the time in
Hollywood.
So, one of the things I picked out of
here was the the uh you know, there's
there's darkness and light in everybody
as if that's the way it's supposed to
be, you know, and I want to challenge
that thought with scripture because I
don't think everybody should be included
in that and certainly not God. 1 John 15
says, "This is the message which you
have heard from the beginning and
declare to you that God is light and in
him is no darkness at all."
Amen.
So this mixture of light and dark is
really something that we see from
Eastern mysticism and things like that.
You know, it's the same kind of stuff we
see in Star Wars. It's the same kind of
thing we see in the martial arts. It's
the same kind of thing you see in um all
kinds of stuff, you know, but typically
other religions, not Christianity. The
mixing of light and dark does not belong
in Christianity at all.
And God was very patient with with
Lucifer in heaven. I mean, there was a
massive amount of pleading with him.
Please don't go down this road. And so,
you know, the devil caused a lot of
this. He's the foundation of all this.
And so to me, this is sort of just
lifting the like, you know, well, he's
really a good person at heart and, you
know, all will be saved in the end. But
this is the most evil person that the
universe is like got in it right now.
Seems like the only good that's
presented in the show is him being what,
like a detective helping in the helping
to solve crimes,
but everything else is just like
destruction, sex, and drugs and just
chaos. Is that the So, you just need a
slither of good and the rest is
Yeah,
that's a redeemable quality. It should
be be redeemed over that.
All right, I want to show you a couple
of things from the show before we really
start to dig into one particular
episode. Okay, these are just like
little brief snippets we're going to go
through just to give you an idea of what
kind of flavor it puts out there as far
as Christianity is concerned.
I'm glad you came back.
I needed to get my parking validated.
So, your items were never recovered?
No.
Earlier you said that the items weren't
that important.
Yet now you seem very upset that they're
gone.
Well, I'm a walking paradox. What can I
say?
Sometimes we need to lose something
before we can understand its value.
I didn't lose anything.
No. No. You were the victim of a crime.
It's only natural that you would feel
violated. And often our feelings of loss
connect to how we feel about who we are.
Right. So, we're back on that, are we?
You want to talk about my identity?
Yes, because you're the devil. You told
me your names, but you left out a few
others. Abadin, Bale, Prince of
Darkness.
Someone's been brushing up on their
Sunday school.
Yes, but before you fell, you were known
as Semile,
the Lightbringer.
I don't go by that name anymore.
That was a name that connotated your
father's love for you.
Right.
Was casting his son into hell also an
expression of his love?
No. Well, God didn't cast you out of
heaven because he was angry with you.
How can you presume to know God's
intentions?
No, I don't. I can't.
Then maybe stick within the limits of
your intellectual capacity.
Or maybe my simplicity offers me a
different perspective. God cast you out
because he needed you to do the most
difficult of jobs.
It was a gift.
Gift. He shunned me. He vilified me. He
made me a torturer.
Can you even begin to fathom what it was
like?
eons spent providing a place for dead
mortals to punish themselves. I mean,
why do they blame me for all their
little failings? As if I'd spent my days
sitting on their shoulder, forcing them
to commit acts they'd otherwise find
repulsive. Oh, the devil made me do it.
I have never made any one of them do
anything. Never.
What happened to you is unfair.
Unfair? This is unjust.
For all eternity, my name will be
invoked to represent all their
depravity. That is the gift that my
father gave me. It was an act of love.
How do you know?
Because you are his favorite son, Sam.
Do not call me that, please.
You are his fallen angel. But here's the
thing. When angels fall, they also rise.
All you have to do is embrace all that
you are.
I can't.
Yes, you can. You just have to be open
to the process.
You don't understand. I can't.
BUT WHY?
BECAUSE I STOLE THEM FROM ME. YOU
[Music]
SO, YOU JUST seen a session that he had
with his therapist and in there a lot of
a lot of things came out a lot of things
about him and how he views his
relationship between God and how she
views it and they're mixing a lot of,
you know, truth and error. One of the
things that came out was a name, Samuel.
And so I thought, hm, that's kind of
curious because she called it like the
lightbearer. And I was like, what?
What is that name? I've never heard that
name before. Where does that come from?
And so as I was digging, I found out
it's a Hebrew name.
And so here's what it actually means. It
means venom of God, poison of God, or
blindness of God.
It does not mean what they were making
it to mean. They're kind of mixing the
Hebrew name with the Greek meaning of
uh Lucifer, right?
There there's a lot there though that I
think we need to bring out that is just
disturbing in and of itself.
Basically making the claim that um God
was the one that forced him out. He did
nothing to get caused that. Yet he's the
one that caused all that dissension in
heaven. So So it's once again shifting
the blame back on God. has nothing to do
with him. I find it very interesting
like in that video we watched before how
he is the a pastor's son. So he's very
aware of all of this terminology. If you
if you're literally grown up in
Christendom and I mean how can you say
that out of your mouth and not question
wow this is really putting a lot of
blame on God.
You know my talks man
right?
So yeah he was saying like people do all
their things on their own. They blame
the devil, but they do it on their
Yeah.
There's like what you're saying like a
little bit of truth. There's truth to
that.
But who was the one that said, "Did God
say,
right? He caused the first influence."
Yeah. Certainly he can't force us, but
he definitely has influence. And so that
that goes along with this name Samuel,
right? In the Talmud, this is the angel
of death and engineered the fall of Adam
and Eve. So we definitely know who we're
talking about here. M
and in Gnostic literature, this name is
the one who planted the tree of
knowledge and tempted Adam to sin. He's
also the one that marries Lilith. Does
that name ring a bell to you? Oh yeah.
So in Gnostic literature, Lilith is the
one I thought this was interesting. They
have a child between them. And you know
what the child's name is?
Adam.
Osmodius.
Osmodius. Interesting. Which is one of
the names of the demons in in the lesser
key of Solomon. I mean it it clearly
states all the people that they've
they've met the demons and know their
names. That's where that comes from.
Osmodius is one of them.
And he actually pops up in movies. There
was a movie called um
um The Watchmen. Osmandius is really
Osodius. Um a lot of the Jokers that
we've seen in Batman and stuff like
that, that's where Osmodius
and in Spawn they had a Osodius like
character. That's
right.
Yeah. So that's who we're talking about.
That's what that name actually means.
not kind of a twist that they put on in
the show.
Well, Hollywood is so consistent. You
have shows talking about the devil or
some kind of devil or demon put in like
a glorified light and looking for
redemption, all these things. And oh,
all this bad stuff isn't my fault.
And then you have the opposite. We
talked about miracle workers. You should
check out that episode um
on Patreon.
Yeah, this oh
YouTube can't watch it on YouTube. Um,
but yeah, God is what, a drunkard and he
doesn't care and he should take all the
blame. Just like this consistent theme
in Hollywood that's so opposite from the
Bible.
And I see that mindset in a
non-believers today. You see that
they're always saying if God was good,
why is all this bad stuff happening? Why
isn't God killing the murderers, killing
the rapist? Well, he did that back when
he flooded the world. And then you say,
"Why would God, you know, the same
breath they say, why would a loving God
destroy all those men, women, children,
animals?"
Yeah,
you can't win. God can't win with this.
In in the Bible, it says that he told
Noah to preach for 120 years. They had
time to get on that ark and they didn't.
And eight people out of the world got
on.
Eight.
That was God's love and mercy. He
protected them from all the murders,
rapist, pedophiles, all that. And God
let it go on like pleading with
humanity, please get on the ark. Please
repent.
Well, I'm gonna save my eight.
And what's interesting is you look at
humanity after those eight when
everything starts over. We just revert
back to our our nature, right? You can't
take those eight people and then
everybody from then on out is perfect.
No, everybody has a choice and you
choose which direction you're going to
go. And since then,
you know, we're told by Jesus that the
end times will be like the days of Noah.
You know, we're coming to that again. We
just we in in our sin, we digress,
right? All right. So, this is a clip of
uh Tom Ellis doing an interview and he
talks a little bit more about his
family. So, he mentioned in the other
clip that his dad was a pastor. It's
actually a little more interesting than
that that we're going to see.
See, but your father's a pastor. How
does he feel about you playing literally
the devil?
Well, we don't talk anymore. Uh joking.
He's like, "You can take this role, but
we're done."
No, he's he's fine. It's not actually
the funny thing is it's not just my dad.
It's my sister and my uncle, our pastors
as well. Um so I it could be said I'm
from a religious family.
Yes.
Um but they're all really great about
it. I mean, they're obviously very
supportive of my career and um I think
anyone that watches the show understands
that it's um there's quite a good
message at the heart of the show. So
actually weirdly for me like the nicest
messages I get are from Christians or
from congregations where people have
embraced the story that we're telling in
order to sort of help tell their story.
Is it kind of fun to play a character
that is just pure evil?
Like you can just live the second life
at the heart of the show. Uh I hope that
at the heart of the show we sort of
tried to prove that there is nothing
such as pure evil or Lucifer isn't pure
evil.
There's more to him than that cuz he was
an angel before he was
the devil.
Right.
What? So, I want to challenge that thing
that he just said that there's a good
message at the heart of the show. Okay?
And that's what we're going to get into
when we start to analyze the episode
that is about God.
I I have to mention this as well, too,
though, because here he's literally
telling you that the majority of people
that are reaching out to him and telling
him they like it come Christian people.
Yeah. That are all of a sudden
identifying with it. I mean, if there's
a show that's literally gonna flip the
Bible upside down and make God out to be
a villain, it's like something like
this, and it's like, if a majority of
Christians are kind of siding with him,
that's disturbing to me.
Yeah. Because if God doesn't redeem him
by the end of the episode, then he's the
bad guy, right?
That's right. It's God that kicked him
out and then now he's not willing to
save him. I mean, that's the message I
got from the one minute clip you played.
He said, "At the heart of there's good
at the heart of the show." Which means
there's so much bad, but at the heart of
it, it's that's good. But when people
open the Bible and they're like, "Oh
man, there's this bad and this bad, so
let's toss the book out." Why don't they
use that same thinking?
So if I give you a gallon of poison and
I throw a vitamin C in it, you going to
drink it?
There's a vitamin in the heart of that.
Come on.
I mean, there's dead at the heart of
Bible. Take how you take that whole
thing as well.
It's crazy.
Yeah. They love to find one little verse
to say, "Yeah, that's why I don't
believe it. It's inconsistent or
whatever." We can find a ton of stuff in
that show and easily throw it out. Yeah.
So,
okay. So, the next question is what
about God?
What do they how do they portray God?
And there's a particular episode. It's
in season two that they encounter this
character. Now, is it really God? No,
it's not really God. But the character's
name is God Johnson. I'm going to set
the stage a little bit. Okay. And
Lucifer encounters this man. There's a
lot of things he can't figure out about
him. So part of his character abilities
is, you know, he can um influence people
to tell the truth, which is I find kind
of ironic because,
you know, the Bible tells us that he's
the father of lies, right? And so he has
this way of bringing the truth out of
people or even bringing their desires
out of people. Like for example, his
therapist, you know, he gets her to
confess like what she really thinks of
him and how she's really attracted to
him.
But he can't do that with this character
and there's a mystery behind it. And so
we have to figure out, you know, through
this whole episode they play out because
he he starts to wonder, is this really
father? Is this really God? And they
have some dialogue that goes back and
forth. And then there's uh a conclusion.
So we're going to go through all that
and I want you to see at the end of the
day, how is God portrayed and the loose
and the relationship between the two of
them? How is it left? Okay. And we'll
then we're getting back to what's really
the message at the heart of this show.
Well, we'll I think we'll know as as
much as it concerns God. Bit of a
warning. There is some language in here,
at least in this next clip. So, sorry if
that offends your ears. We're not trying
to do that. It's just part of the scene.
Well, hello God.
Hello, my son.
Right. Yes. I suppose that would be the
standard way to greet your children.
Nice touch.
What can I do for you?
Well, it's what I can do for you that's
exciting. See, I can reveal the truth
about the supreme being you've chosen to
impersonate. I bet you wanted to be God
cuz he's benevolent, all powerful, yada
yada. But in actual fact, he's a
Look,
you won't be angry with me.
Just go right on ahead.
I can be anything you need me to be.
Right,
enough of this idol chitchat. Time to
tell me what the Shira's really about.
What do you desire? H to avoid a
vengeful X-wear of back taxes. What's
your game?
Is this staring contest? Cuz you know
I'm pretty good at those.
How's this possible?
Oh, right. Yes. I bet you're on some
really amazing drugs, aren't you? If so,
cheers.
You're not supposed to be in here.
Never mind. Done with this fraud.
Anyway,
it's a real good seeing you, Samuel.
What did you say?
Dad.
Okay. So, here's his first encounter
with this God Johnson character.
My ears hurt.
Yeah.
Pretty blasphemous. You know what he
says about God. Yeah. Um
calls him a name that we cannot even say
and repeat, right?
And then basically is literally like I
mean this is this terrible portrayal.
How can this guy say honestly that that
there's a good message at the heart of
of of these stories? So the next clip is
we're going to show you an illusion to a
plan that um he has with his mother.
Yes. They bring in mom into this season
as well. They call her the divine
goddess. So, here we go again, mixing
elements that are not Christianity into
Christianity. Uh, or at least a show
that is supposed to have a basis in
Christianity according to the producers.
So, I just want you to hear like part of
their plan in regards to God.
What's he doing here, Lucifer?
I don't know. You married him. kind of
ruins our plans to storm the gates of
heaven and destroy him.
Well, I'm thinking we might not need to
do that anymore.
Okay. She finishes her sentences by
saying, "I will never forgive him." But
the plan storm the gates of heaven and
destroy God.
Destroy God.
Wow.
And she's married. She was married to
God.
Yeah. She was supposed to be married to
him. She somehow got
cast from heaven or banished or
something and her soul wound up in hell
and got freed.
It's very so on a strange
on a deep spiritual level
a woman is a church.
Interesting. Supposed to be married to
God.
Mhm.
Literally behind his back is courting
and in love with Lucifer.
I mean this is literally like hitting at
the core of of of Christianity has has
had a struggle. I mean that's why
Revelation talks about a woman riding a
beast. I mean this is very like
prophetic even how they're putting this
out there.
The heart of the church. the heart of
the church playing a harlot with the
with the man of sin. So, this next clip
we're going to see um another exchange
and dialogue that happens between him
and God Johnson and they've been
captured by a crazy nurse. She manages
to capture them, pump them full of
drugs. They're here captured on in a
like an old hospital or insane asylum or
something like that. And um she is
trying to she's going to kill them.
Okay. But they have some dialogue
between the two of them as this um is
going playing out. So I want you to hear
what they have to say.
I had no idea you were so angry with me.
Really? Is that I've been pretty upfront
about it.
But to want to destroy me? That's pretty
serious.
You mind telling me why?
Because
because I'm your son
and
you rejected me.
Oh,
well then I guess I can't say as I blame
you. Fact of the matter is I don't even
remember why I was ever so angry with
you to begin with.
For what it's worth,
I am sorry.
I truly am.
And I am proud of you, Samuel.
I'm proud of the man you've become.
I
I'm still having a hard time finding the
little nugget of goodness inside of
this.
Well, because it's a father forgiving
his son.
Well, this is one one episode. Okay.
This is the father who's supposed to be
God and
he's the one that needs to say he's
sorry. Yeah. and that literally he's
proud of who he's become. I I think this
just saddens the heart of God. He is
very brokenhearted that Lucifer did what
he did and in his defiance would be
willing to kill God when God didn't
deserve any of that. Wow. This is just a
total reversal.
They're adding a lot to the character of
Satan and stripping away a lot from God.
Now, I'm not going to make and all these
things.
I'm not going to make a big deal about
this, but his last name is what?
Johnson.
Oh, Johnson. So, you guys ever remember
those big Johnson t-shirts?
Yeah.
No,
I mean, you could probably chop that.
Yeah. I mean, they even That's what
Lucifer
That's why he called him that.
I guarantee you that plays into it.
What am I missing?
I don't know. I'm not familiar either,
but let's see how this episode.
Big Johnson is another name for it.
Okay.
Yeah,
we're going to see how this ends.
I still can't believe I gave all my
money away. Well, if it's any
consolation, you haven't exactly been
yourself of late.
Yeah.
Listen, I wanted to ask you, what's the
last thing you remember?
I was in New Mexico for work. Was
walking through this Navajo gift shop,
saw his cool belt buckle. I picked it up
and next thing I knew, I woke up
strapped to a gurnie next to you.
Lucky are you?
Yeah.
Hey, they uh they said we was arguing.
If I did or said something to upset you,
I apologize.
No, no, you were quite lovely, actually.
For a brief moment, I thought you were
my father.
Man, for whom I harbor a great deal of
resentment.
And you said some things that I think I
wish he'd always said to me. So for
that, I thank you.
Well, I guess even a blind squirrel
catches a nut every now and then.
Take care of yourself.
Hey, does this mean you're not angry at
your dad anymore?
No, I'm not angry.
I'm bloody furious.
I realize that my father would never say
those things to me. And for that,
I hate him all the more.
[Applause]
Well, what a message.
Okay, so this character winds up, it
turns out he's actually not God, as you
probably discerned from that clip. What
happened was that belt buckle that he
had, that piece winds up belonging on
the flaming sword. It's part of it. So,
it's something that God created. And so,
this piece is like an artifact that has
special powers. And, you know, the
person that has possession of it is able
to do certain things. So, that's why he
was able to resist Lucifer. It's able
why, you know, he couldn't have his mind
read. It's able why he could uh fool the
divine goddess and all these things. He
had these special powers and abilities.
But in the end, you know, he had he had
said some things and then Lucifer was
hoping those things would be true. And
then what does he say, you know, when he
finds out that they're not?
I hate God all the more.
I hate God all the more. So, this is the
message that they're sending about God.
He's He's not redemptive.
No,
it's a show about forgiveness.
God's not forgiving
and therefore he should be hated all the
more because of it. because he's not not
forgiving Lucifer.
Wow.
So, it's a strong message. I did a
little digging since this is in season
5. Season 5 is not out yet. It's soon to
be released on Netflix, um I think. And
people have already started making
petitions for season 6.
Wow.
And I just looked this up the other day.
It's on change.org where you can make
petitions about all kinds of things. And
almost 100,000 people have signed this
petition that this have another season,
season six, and they're trying to get to
150,000 signatures. Now, from time to
time, you know, people will petition
Hollywood to extend certain shows. So,
will we get a season 6? I don't know.
They do introduce other biblical
characters. They introduce the character
of Cain. Um, they call him the sinner
man. And uh it turns out that Cain is a
murderer in that episode just like you
know Kane is in the Bible. And they
introduce the character of Eve.
Um and they they spin that as she is
Lucifer's s first love.
So when she shows up, you know, it's
just like
an old flame.
Hey. Yeah. Like an old fling, an old
flame.
And they're just doing their thing
together, you know.
Wow.
Um
so so look at media. I'm sitting here
thinking, you know, it's always
interesting, like you said earlier, how
you have shows about the devil or Satan
or whatnot, and they're always portrayed
in a good light. And I think about that,
like, of course, you know, you have the
biggest mass media tool on the planet,
right? Is the devil going to leave that
alone? No.
Is he going to take that mass media tool
and say, "Well, let's see if we can make
God as as good as he can possibly look."
No, he's going to do the exact opposite.
is going to make himself look as look as
good as he can and then God is going to
be minimized or vilified in that
process.
I think there's always a reason why the
devil is trying to um basically make a
logical excuse for what he's done.
Yeah.
And and he's trying to like get people
to say, "Oh, now I understand why you
did what you did because of X, Y, and
Z." When really it's the mystery of
iniquity. There is no explanation for
why Lucifer did what he did and where it
came from out of nothing in a perfect
environment to drag down part of God's
exist existing universe he has no
answers for. And so this is just like
getting people to side with him. And
then yeah, I see nothing but a a slam on
God and a deflection of of really what
we should be saying as a society. Like
man, we there's a lot of pain. There's a
lot of misery. Why do people always put
that on God? Why don't they put it where
it's that it's due and that's on Satan?
Yeah.
So there's two things I want to point
out from the Bible that we know as the
truth of this character Lucifer. like
what is what are his characteristics
right what is he really trying to do so
the first one can be found in revelation
12:9 and the thing I want to bring out
of this is that he deceives the whole
world so deception is part of his nature
we said earlier he's the father of lies
right so what is he trying to do he's
trying to deceive everyone on this
planet according to the Bible which is
the truth right so you can take a show
like Lucifer and you know it can be all
funny and satirical or or whatever you
want to say, but at the end of the day,
this is the true nature of that
character is deception. The next one is
he's the accuser, which means he has no
love for you or I.
Bible says he's the accuser of the
brethren. That's each one of us. And he
will not hesitate to throw you under the
bus. In fact, he'll do his best to get
you to sin and then take it right to God
and say like, "Look what those terrible
people did and why they should be
destroyed."
So, he is not on your side at all. He is
the accuser. So, he's the deceiver and
the accuser. And we also see a picture
of this in Zechariah chapter 3. It says,
"Then he showed me Joshua, the high
priest, standing before the angel of the
Lord and Satan standing at his right
hand to oppose him." Satan was there in
that scene as the accuser as well. Um,
so that's his nature. That's who he is.
That's what he's always trying to do.
He's always trying to destroy humanity,
deceive the world. So don't be deceived
by this character. Now,
I don't know if it's just me, but maybe
Christians with shows like this are
starting to lose their discernment.
And here is a Instagram clip I snagged
from a famous artist. Her name is Kelly
Clarkson. You might have heard of her.
She won the first season of American
Idol. And she's actually a Southern
Baptist.
Um, so this is what she had to say about
the show Lucifer. I'm gonna show you
this clip.
Okay, I'm upset because it took me
forever to catch on to this show because
I have four children and a lot of jobs
and a lot going on. But I cannot believe
my sister was like, "You need to watch
the show. you're going to love this
show. You're going to love this show.
And I kept trying and every time I did,
there was a kid. There was something who
was happening. So, I never got to. And
then I finally started watching it. And
then I obsessively
watched three seasons in like four days.
My husband is so over it probably. But I
love it. And the show is called Lucifer.
And I'm so mad because I just found out
because I was so happy because Netflix
picked it up. And so then I started
watching season four and then I noticed
that somebody had said season five was
the last season and they were like, "Oh,
but don't worry, we added six shows." So
apparently there's now 16 shows instead
of 10 in season five. But here's what I
need Netflix. Like what do we need to do
to make sure there's more seasons than
just season five? Because here's what
happens. I get on a show like late in
the game and it's amazing and then
people end up going, "Oh, it's over."
And it's canceled. And I'm like, "Why?"
And I'm mad about it. Anyway, if you
haven't watched Lucifer, you should
watch it. It's awesome. The end of
season four. Let's talk about it. It's
so good and sad. I'm obsessed. It's
fine. Anyway, I want them on my show. I
want Amy Garcia on my show. I want all
of them on my show. I might have texted
Amy Garcia because we have the same hair
guy. Robert Ramos. Roberto Ramos. And I
love her and I love the show. Anyway, if
you haven't watched it and you're like,
man, what's a good show I should watch?
Lucifer. trust. Like the first three
seasons I watched on iTunes, like on
Apple and then well, I bought them. I
support Art. Um and then um season 4 and
five isn't even come out until freaking
spring or summer 2020, whatever. But
anyway, season 4 is on Netflix. Netflix,
how about y'all go ahead and reup that
and you just do me a solid and continue
this greatness. Okay, bye.
Wow.
I really didn't know which direction she
was going to go with this video. It
sounded almost like she was like,
"Someone's trying to get me to watch
Lucifer and I watch it. It's a horrible
show." Instead, I, you know, shocked
when she was like, "I'm obsessed with
it."
I think it speaks to mainstream
Christianity. I mean, it's like, are we
not reading the Bible? I mean, like, are
we not familiar with this this age-old
story of how God and Satan began in this
war? Because if you are, you know, if
you've grown up with this um, you know,
Christian upbringing and and and you
could be drawn to something like this
and it's not offensive to you or it's
not like, ah, whoa, whoa, they just like
slam my God.
Um, that's this is like alarming to me
that this is where Christian and I'm
sure we're going to get comments in this
video even like, "Whatever, you guys are
just looking into stuff like we always
do." And it's like, "Yeah, but when was
the last time you really saw a show like
this put it in its proper light?" I
mean, if a show like this called Lucifer
was showing you that the devil is who is
the the the destroyer of people that you
need to run to God, I mean, dude, we'd
be doing a show praising this type of a
of a of a show. But it's so opposite.
I want to wrap things up here with a
couple of verses. I think Ephesians 5
really speaks to this well and and what
we should be uh our attitude towards
these kind of things. It says in verses
1 and 2, therefore be imitators of God
as dear children and walk in love as
Christ also has loved us and given
himself for us in offering and a
sacrifice to God for a sweet smelling
aroma. I didn't hear anything in this
show about God sacrificing himself or
anything like that. It was all
one-sided. God is a villain. You know,
he he it was all, you know, sympathy for
the devil. He vilified me forever and
he's this terrible person.
And then verses 5'8 says, "For you were
once in darkness, but now you are light
in the world. Walk as children in the
light." That's the admonition we get
from the Bible is walk as children in
the light. Not spending our time in the
darkness. Not spending our time with
dark shows that have really dark
messages
and searching for the good in the
darkness. Yeah.
Oh, man.
Searching for the good and the darkness.
No, because the Bible says, you know,
good and evil are not to be mixed.
They're not the same thing, and they
can't be flip-flopped either. Good is
good, evil is evil. Scotty, we were
talking um just between shots. And you
brought out some really interesting
points. Would you share those as we're
starting to wrap up here and get
everybody's final thoughts?
Was that what we were talking about, the
woman and and falling in love with
Lucifer and that being symbol of the
church?
The favorite son.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, in the in one
of the earlier clips that we um actually
were watching in the very beginning of
this, remember he said that um he was
the favored son of God. And you think
about that like who's the favorite son
of God?
Jesus.
That's Jesus. Right? I mean, that's when
Jesus like hears the voice of God after
his baptism. This is my son whom I am
well pleased. Right? We have no biblical
reference whatsoever from God saying
that he's pleased with anything that
Lucifer does. In fact, he says there's
nothing good in him. He was a murderer
from the very beginning is how the Bible
describes that. So the fact that they
put this out there really is interesting
to me because you know like the
billboards that they were doing in New
York to promote this said Lucifer is
coming or second coming of Lucifer. And
so if he's the favored son, he's the one
that's second coming. We saw the picture
where it says he is risen. Who are they
basically replacing?
Familiar.
He's Jesus.
They're putting a lot of twisted stuff
out there. Most people aren't going to
research the name Samuel or whatever and
find out that what they said was a
complete lie.
Um,
yeah,
they have been lying to you in the show.
Like, like that's even another reason
why it's like this is just full of of
nonsense.
And if people just watch this, they
might actually believe, yeah, Lucifer
was one of God's sons or whatever.
Yeah. If you don't know your Bible,
Yeah. how would you know the difference?
I think Mormonisms even say that uh
Lucifer and Jesus were brothers. Now,
can just a just a secondary real quick
um danger to this kind of material going
out into our public, right? Um we know
or we believe we're at the end of this
thing, right?
And what are we supposed to be doing as
Christians?
We're supposed to be running around
knocking on doors trying to share Christ
with people
in the last moments of God's mercy to
come into his fold. Right? So, let's
just hypothetically say you were exposed
to this and somebody knocks on your door
and starts trying to tell you what God
is like. It's just it's just conflicting
information and these seeds have been
planted into people's minds. And so by
the time you go to share with them, they
don't even understand why they hate God
or they're angry with God. But it's like
if you watched all of these things and
and I mean a Christian like Kelly
Clarkson couldn't see that there's a
problem with this
man that Lord have mercy on those people
that that don't know Christ right now. A
thought that came to mind is wow
Christians are like one of the most
disloyal people groups of people to
their own religion
because you know um I remember there was
a show or movie that showed Bafomet
remember what it was and the satanic
groups sat was it um Sabrina
and the satanic groups were like
copyright you know take it down and show
him the wrong light exactly but when it
comes to biblical themes in shows that
are completely just skewing and and
contradicting what's in the Bible.
Christians are like, "Yeah, let's find
the good. Let's watch it. Let's support
it." And, you know, let's put it on for
another season. It's just like, "Wow,
like
or should we not be offended? Should we
not be doing something about this?" And
as you're saying, you know, making sure
that when we go out there to share
truth, there's not this mass
contradicting message to to fight
against.
It's like the devil has a louder tool to
beat us to the punch and then we're
trying to play catchup to share
information. Uh, no. God's really like
this this, you know, loving nice
character and God is love. I mean, that
if the whole Bible literally is a
description of God's love. This just
missed the entire point of the Bible.
Yet, they say they went to the Bible to
get their information to make the show
in the first place.
Yeah.
And that's if we're sharing it at all. I
mean, if we're cons if that's consuming
all of our time, do we have time to
share the truth, the word of God?
Yeah, that's right. They say the show is
about redemption, but I never saw any
redemption. It just looked like God is
not redeeming.
That's true. Redemption was a lie. Like
it wasn't God
or you know there's as different
episodes play out, redemption seems to
be for everybody but God or more for
Lucifer than anybody else.
Wow.
So,
but it's that that that thing that
really I think irked me with all the
clips that you just showed me was that
God really needs to say sorry to the
devil.
And and to me I'm I'm massively offended
by that.
Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, I've gone through a lot of pain
in this world, and you know, for me to
sit there and say, "God, it's your
fault."
Yeah. We've humbled ourselves and and
repented and told God we're sorry.
That's right.
We haven't done near the stuff that he
has done.
That's right.
Yep. If you want to see some extra
scenes to this, we're going to throw up
a special little clip of us having some
extra dialogue and throw in another clip
that we um analyze from uh the show and
you can catch that on Patreon. So, we
encourage you to go to Patreon and find
the behind the scenes or extra scenes
for this episode. And if you literally
want to become a supporter of of our LED
show, I mean, definitely check out our
Patreon because think about this, a lot
of people will pay for Netflix or go and
see these movies or TV shows and it's
like they're giving their time, money,
energy to this kind of junk when uh you
know, I I would hope that those
Christians are are are helping support
ministries and stuff like that. So, we
need your help. If you got, you know,
any extra
funds that you can help us to create new
things, we would be greatly appreciated.
All right. So, what does the show
Lucifer teach us about God? Well, you
found out here on LED live. You can make
your own judgment. Make sure you put
your comments below. And also, if you
like this kind of material, make sure
you like this channel, subscribe to this
channel, hit that notification bell so
you can be notified when the next
episodes are out. And uh we hope to
catch you next time on LED Live. Thanks
for watching.
Bye.
[Music]